lonnie i got to tell you i was looking
at your instagram story the zoom life
is not doing that outfit justice you
look amazing the at the toe look
trust me thank you so much but trust me
it is definitely different than what i'm
used to
it is stressing yeah absolutely
he's going for that campaign he's
getting he's going to get that campaign
you watch
yeah okay guys david isn't here
give me the lowdown how was he as a
director
zero start with you like directorial
debut how did he do
hands down unbelievable like on a whole
other stratosphere
just so present so on top of it he'd
been
working on the script for years and
developing you know
everything from the location to the cast
everything they had another director
director fell through
he stepped in the final hour and it was
seamless
like really he's he you know he he's a
great one if you get a chance to
interview him to just hear
all of the different directors that he'd
worked with that he downloaded from and
got sort of cliff notes
to kind of hit the ground running with
us and you would never have thought that
this was his directorial debut i mean it
was
really it was it was such a he had such
a great way of getting us
all on on board with his vision and i
think the film is a testament to just
how brilliantly he pulled that off
yeah lonnie thoughts give me the scoop
come on a hundred percent with mr zario
said he definitely set a tone
that i remember the first day that we
had uh that we had worked together he
put us all in a circle and we prayed
together and said that we're all gonna
do this with love
kindness treat everybody how you want to
be treated and that is exactly what we
did throughout the whole
entire set he had patience with
everybody it doesn't matter if they were
rooted or not
honestly and he always taught me to be a
leader and not a follower
yeah rosario found it so cool that
david's wife
wrote that lullaby that you sing in the
movie like was that in place before
uh you filmed or was that did that come
about while you're filming no i mean
that that
that showed up i remember seeing that
pop up in this script and and i had no
idea what the history was
of it until we started rehearsing it and
then i felt like
profound pressure to kind of push this
um but it was it was just it was lovely
it was so many little touches like that
that just make this film
so david's and like you know just the
community of people that he pulled
together
to to kind of you know usher this story
out to the world
um you know was just really dynamic i
mean
there was so much care and
thoughtfulness put into every single
aspect every single moment
um and i think you can feel that
sensitivity
and that vulnerability and that intimacy
so thoroughly in something that still
feels like a big adventure kid film
family film with magical realism in it
like it's still so grounded
and i think that's what's gonna make it
stand the test of time like so many of
the other great
sort of films like et and goonies and
stand by me that we love is that there's
such dignity to the joy
that is put in yeah yeah lonnie we
talked mean you talked a lot about this
is us
um last fall we talked about this movie
at tiff do you find that
this is us that it gets you
opportunities like rules like this or do
you find that people
box you in and only want to see you as
randall
um to be honest i feel like a lot of
people only see me as randalls
i mean i've met a lot of people that
will be like oh it's young around on
monday and i'll be like
name's
i mean there's a lot of other projects
that i've done but apparently this
seems to stick out right and so yeah
like getting a role like this like how
does it feel to get like a big role like
this that's
very different from this is us this role
was honestly
perfect i mean i felt blessed by by
jesus christ of this role came to me
this world was
challenging i feel like this world
definitely pushed my limits and i feel
like i'm a better man and a better actor
than i was before
yeah you were awesome in it speaking of
fan bases rosario
how you feeling about this star wars fan
base coming at you now like is it a
whole different thing
that now you're part of like the star
wars world oh yeah
like it's been interesting because you
know the past couple of years
have sort of put me into different
spheres than i'm normally used to being
in i mean i've been in
politics for a long time with my voting
organization and stuff like that but
it's a very different thing when you're
dating a politician
um and i've been acting for a lot of
years and had a lot of different
kind of roles that become cult classics
and things like that and
and you know it's been you know 20-year
anniversary of jose and the pussycats
and kids and
all of you things you know and you know
you always think it's like okay it's
rent it was that big
film for me but then you get into star
wars and that fandom i mean
i thought the rent fandom was you know
the rent heads were like a whole thing
this is like
a whole other stratosphere you know and
it just makes me feel like
i'm just i'm giving myself up that i'm
not going to be that person who knows
like every
idiosyncratic factoid about the star
wars universe like because i've already
had like
10 year olds out detail me
like so i'm like well clearly you
watched that
20 times and i watched it twice and so
we're not gonna we're not we're not
doing the same things i'm just gonna
make sure
as much as possible the right way boom
boom and and you know save my lines and
and then i'll let you all take it from
here yeah i don't know if the spin-off's
definitely happening but i hope to see
it yeah congratulations on this movie
guys
i saw it twice now see i really really
enjoyed it oh wow that's awesome
thank you thank you have a great day